The formula for
the area of rectangles seems intuitive.
Trying to find the area of a triangle is
not as straightforward as trying to find
the area of a rectangle.
However, with the help
of some origami paper,
I think we will be
able to figure it out.
The area is 4x4 equals 16 square inches.
If we take that piece of paper and
fold it in half diagonally,
we have a triangle whose base
is still four inches and
whose height is still four inches.
Remembering that the area of the whole
square is 16, what is your guess of
what the area of the triangle might be,
if it's just a folded in half square?
What is the area of a triangle with
base equals 4 and height equals 4?
Enter your answer here and
don't worry about units.
[BLANK_AUDIO]